[Applause]
thank you very much i appreciate that
i think i know why you're happy today
it's first of all it's spring almost
spring we had patrick day
we love spring
and also uh we finally did something
together in this country uh the senate
voted unanimously wouldn't have ever
heard that
to get keep daylight savings time
permanent
something it's something
yeah no of course because this is
america and everyone has to [ __ ]
there are some people who say no we
shouldn't do that because it will
deprive our bio biological clocks
of critical light sense
okay for [ __ ] sake just go with
something would you i mean
you know if
first of all
it doesn't take effect until spring of
2023 maybe by then we'll be sleeping
inside
if you want to lose an hour take the
405. you know
just go with
something i'm trying to feel good
and i i think you know in a lot of ways
things are looking up finally we have a
president that everybody loves and his
approval ratings are sky-high it's the
president of ukraine but still
uh it's something
yes how about boy
he is no bigger star than zelinski these
days boy and a comedian he's a comedian
he's one of us and he's the biggest
[ __ ] in the world
and he made it uh you saw the speech he
made an amazingly impassioned speech to
our congress obviously not in person he
couldn't do that but he said you have no
idea what it's like to have your capital
under siege
uh
well we do a little
but uh
it was an amazing speech again from a
comedian how great is that he made his
case for military aid uh he made his
case for a democracy he he compared the
attack on his country to pearl harbor
and 9 11. and then he did his dating
hunk
and that killed
no he's got big shtick energy this guy
he really does
he is uh
you know who loves him women are going
nuts for have you seen that uh
oh they're
oh they love it
he's like the sexiest man alive now in
fact
you know what women are saying now you
know that thing they always wanted men
to do when men are servicing the lady
parts down there
that where they would spell out the
alphabet with their tongue
remember that
now they want them to spell out
velodomore zielinski
[Applause]
you